du hast mich über den tisch gezogen
alter was haben die geile preise oder
rüdiger der braucht 20 wolle für ein
smaragd die einfach ist das denn
guck dir denn hier der blubbert dass
sich rüdiger der volontär ich weiß aber
der andere rüdiger der internet steht
aber daran dass markus pennen gehn
wartet dann hole ich mir ja kohle aus
alle waffen steile wand rechts gibt es
das nur nebenbei hatte ich töte welche
reisen schwert meine erfahrung zurück in
die tiefen der unterwelt wo die elcom
ist so kann spam
es wird alles dunkel und es ist ja gut
also ich wollte mir meinen mann besitzt
die mal erholen aber hier ist nun
kräftig mit ein bett das heißt ich lass
das jetzt mal so stehen und kräfte meine
kiste
ich gehe jetzt mal auf expedition stour
guckst du einfach so ein paar sachen an
oder wie
ja ich werde mir ein paar sachen
angucken ich könnte mal ein bisschen was
sammeln so was man so braucht um ihr
leben
ich hab mir was schönes nalecz fragment
und feuerkugel ich sehe zwei creeper
sehr daran interessiert erst mal
das höchste level der erfahrung zu
erreichen sagt ich mal so level 30 oder
so und dann ist was denn creepers
explodiert aber nur in der pampa
irgendwo ich habe hier so eine kiste das
ist mein okay das ist hier die oben im
turm
naja dann wollte ich erst mal ein
schwert in chan irgendwie sowas weil ich
habe einmal schlechte erfahrungen mit
mops also vorsorge so dann wäre ich
jetzt ein bisschen kohle wohl nämlich
damit dem rüdiger oder her oder ich
brauche mir erstmal haus das wir
natürlich erst mal eine sache die tore
machten eigentlich auch wieder weiter
handeln unter der zu gute preise dachte
ich wow da muss dann natürlich zu
schlagen
der kontakt zu der ausgefuchste format
ich gehe heirat mal so im werk hoch über
unseren villiger dorf und schauen wir
mal was hier so gibt wenn du irgendwann
zu viel erde hast du kannst mir das
gerne geht nicht von der menge um hier
beginnen die was aus zu stopfen löcher
oder so was mache ich gerne natürlich
nur gegen den guten preis versteht sich
ich kann der dafür eine blume beschenkt
ja das finde ich sehr fairer preis ich
würde sagen 13 stück erde liegen einem
gut
ja ich bitte zu sagen mit 30 36 69
dann ist eine halbe blume ok-chef hat
angst abgebaut also neues erste was man
nicht in der steiner karton genetisch
eisenack produkt braucht es dann einfach
verschwunden
was das herz der das kann ich ab und
china so komisch amt bleibt ich brauche
jetzt einfach mal attraktiv okay guten
appetit
ich habe keine ahnung was das hier für
einen tag ist eine richtung üblichen
werk höhle
ich sehe hier gerade so einen richtig
epischen höhleneingang
ich sehe so viel mehr ich mache jetzt
erstmal sachen einmal hin erhöhen
expeditionen mach du das mal wenn du
wenn er das denkt ganz gut dass wir so
ein bisschen unterschiedliche rumlaufen
da können wir von unseren gegenseitigen
erlebnissen ein bisschen berichten ist
ganz gut
hier ist kohle das schon mal gut die
braucht der rüdiger jahr für seinen us
markt der gläubiger rödiger was machst
du schon wieder das kind nicht er ist
ein komischer besser stein mit in der
höhle okay ich weiß nicht was es ist als
der stein der weis s marmor oder stein
erweisen
marvel aber hatte so etwas aber ich habe
es gereicht hat nicht genau ich könnte
mal kurz in meinem handy diktators
aktionäre gucken
ich verstehe musik und nebenbei einfach
je weiter abbauen nicht ständig im kreis
um mich herum ab dynamo hat aber sehr
schön aus weißem marmor boden oder ihn
wie so was glaube ich oder als
toilettenschüssel rahmen ihres trifft
ist passend der dax gut wenn man ganz
kurz vor meiner packe das nicht etwas
fragen heute gerade wo wir das mit dem
schlechten witzen und ich verstehe dich
kannst du diesen youtube werbung scheiß
hast du einfach weitere lasten zunächst
kapitalien einfach aus prinzip keine
netlog einem adblocker drin sagt was
nicht auch keine drin und ich guck mir
immer die werbung an weil ich mich auch
immer interessierte was für werbung vor
welchen kanal so läuft und im moment
treten die werbung regt mich so auch von
preisvergleich.de mit diesem kennst du
bestimmt also ist eine frau oder
irgendwelche richtig schlecht geteilten
schauspieler die wirklich also die man
kaum ertragen kann man reden und dann
ist einmal dieser kretzschmar dieser
handball-nationalspieler arbeitsstellen
kretschmer ihm so alles genau und er
sagt dann irgendwie am ende immer als
die frau redet auch etwas was kein
mensch versteht oder sagt er ich
verstehe nur preisvergleich
schwachstellen und preisvergleich bei
mir ist es zurzeit so dass nur sehr
geile werbung und zwar von insgesamt
drei amerikanischen leed ist in seinem
regal
das ist eine ganz tolle werbung besitzen
jetzt nicht so nervtötenden was anderes
ich brauche erstmal holzverkauf versucht
in sein haus rein zu bauen aber ich hab
so viel zu viel für eine heute
gebräuchlich holz ich habe hier aber
zwei holz
crafting table ja ich hab's ich hab den
boden vom haus erreicht gehabt einen
holzboden drin ja deutliche hoch was
finden was für ein haus wo bist du bitte
da oben ganz oben ein winterdorf ist so
ein haus auf dem berg irgendwie
vielleicht ob das bak ist oder ob es
stimmt dass hast du schon mal gezeigt
genau
und auch hier ist extrem schade wird auf
die epische tue gehofft um dich so
richtig zuordnen
das ist aber leider sind nur in der
spiegel
ach die sind nur nachspielen wieder was
gelernt ich keine ahnung irgendwie vom
vom spiel oder es ist vom regulären
minecraft spiel wenig wenig aber von pvp
also für vp passt mal auf und zieh dich
warm an
ich sag nur du deine problemen will
kammer wird es meine da sieht man schon
gewissen unterschied erkannt
hust hust stellt das bisschen charybdis
das bisschen könnte man ihn einfach in
die kommentare schreiben ob er selber
auf trouble in meinen will spielt wird
nicht mehr interessieren weil egal auf
welchem server wir gehen da muss man ja
mittlerweile schon wieder sagen weil wir
halt auch zusammen spielen aber es kaum
halten erläuterte zum spiel heraus
kontrakte es ist wirklich immer so und
jeder kennt 71 prozent auf einem server
kennen ändern
und wenn man sich nicht verkleidet dann
wären 1000 mal einfach nur rennen
gekillt worden weil die leute dann die
mine aufnahme kommt denkt man den
aufwand blauen plan aber mich würde
interessieren wer von euch problem wenn
wir später so schreibt einfach in die
kommentare
oder was ist eine epische krasse höhle
also nicht wo in der katarischen
regierung oder das was da los da ist ein
skelett overall treppe nicht nur rüstung
um den zu bieten comeback kommen
war wie zu bieten errungenschaft erzählt
monsterjäger oder ist ein billiger
zombie war das jetzt ein komisches
gletschern anderes oder wie ein ganz
normales geld aber ich lege ich weiß
nicht wo er ist kommt oder das waren
vogelzug und bitte bitte bitte lieber
gott nein ich wollte sagt man du tot
bist dann hole ich mir deine xp ganz
noch nicht einmal da oben ja genau und
da sind da ist wenn man reingeht es dass
eine große halle direkt vis-a-vis am
krater wie oh ja genau wieso krater hast
du auch schon gefunden
ich finde hier andauernd ich bin eher im
singleplayer rom geflogen
das intro zu machen muss sich auf
ungefähr 30 von solchen komischen
bildern machen und die einfach ein frame
hintereinander packen von haydn arbeite
da ist noch ein skelett und dahinter
wieder schläge kassiert von dieses
skelett vorhin vor paar minuten ja ich
bin hier ja der pvg und clips steht der
cvp und pvm ist unterschied player
versus player place mob
ich habe das keine rolle
die muss ich jetzt erforschen eine
spitzhacke wollte was kraft ab soll nur
aus der box raus noch gewollt dass etwas
kräften
ich wollte dass ich setze so viel
fackeln damit die monster wiederkommen
da ist das geld weg war verschwinde du
ratte
ich bin nicht in der höhle ich glaube
ich habe auch marmor gefunden wenn es
das ist das so ein leuchtend weißer
stein es ist einleuchtend nicht
aluminium ok-chef aluminium gefunden
heißt was das aluminium aluminium weißt
ja aber wie geht das auch aus meine ich
es sieht auch so weiß aus also sollte
man jetzt hier eher abbauen frage ich
mich gerade nochmal hier zuschauer wo
solche adapter
m
ja
weil hier dieses schönen ganzen sachen
freilegen
ich bin um später archäologe ich finde
das ja sehr geil mit dem mini map
eigentlich oben dass man da immer sieht
okay da bin ich und ich finde es
eigentlich ganz cool da wir direkt am
spot- und zehn bewerten wenn wir sterben
damit man zwar auf müssen vielleicht
würde wie ich das klingt gar keine höhle
festnahme ach so du bist über mir das
ist ich sehe dich da sich so in wohnen
siehst du meinen namen euro ist ein
bisschen der höhe darunter bei meinem
haus gewollt ich erforschen jetzt so
viele höhlen sind diese fehler hell und
reisen dann könnt ihr direkt ohne eine
spitzhacke haben machen die du schon
hast und die euch gefunden mir nicht
gemacht in diesem land oft direkt in die
mine gelaufen
durak wenig miteinander sondern in denen
die schmiede
ich weiß aber da gehen wir kurse finden
oder bist du gerade wirklich tief in den
ewig rennen gehen hofft jetzt eben jetzt
ist die erstes erst die erste aufnahme
ist schon lange vorbei ist
wir sind bestimmt schon bei 20 minuten
ich weiß gar nicht wissen warum fast nur
noch ersten wahrscheinlich die zweite
aufnahme oder
okay doch schon müssen wir die gleiche
haben ungefähr oder vergabe für 13
minuten platz weil mit intro vor und
alles im plan
okay das u14 und das ist gut gut wenn
mir das täglich bringen sind 13 minuten
kommentieren